on today's visual studio toolbox tarik
is going to show us how to get started
with Python development using Visual
Studio code hi welcome to visual studio
toolbox I'm your host Robert Greene and
joining me today is Tyreke white hey
Tyreke hi Robert thanks for having me
thanks for being on the show yeah I'm
Tyreke white everyone and I'm a program
manager for Python developer tools here
at Microsoft cool so we're gonna talk
about doing some Python we're gonna show
Visual Studio code right that's awesome
so give us again the very brief because
I think we've talked about it before but
the very brief sweet spot for python is
a c-sharp developer or a JavaScript
developer when and why should I learn
Python what are the scenarios that are
most prevalent definitely so Robert
excellent question when we get a lot at
conferences Python the sweet spot for
Python is quickly or being able to build
apps quickly one of my demos later I'm
going to show in nine lines of code I'm
able to create I'll be at a very simple
web application I still create a web
application and that's kind of the basis
for Python it's the scrappy language
where people are able to prototype
quickly but it's also used for
production code as well which is super
exciting okay yeah cool yeah awesome
and so today specifically we're gonna
talk about Python and vs code and for
any of those who don't know vs code is
this free open source cross-platform
tool which uses a popular popular
popular riced extension model for every
language right and so today we're gonna
talk about the Python extension and vs
code and getting started experience
and then later my colleague Jeffrey will
be talking about data science and vs
code for Python develop that would be
another episode that will record after
this one definitely showing people the
behind the scenes of how it works here
in the studio right be why I'm wearing
the same shirt awesome cool so let's get
started so so the Python extension
offers a lot of great jam-packed
features it offers intellisense
debugging
staying there support for virtual
environment packages like Virgil's like
VNV and Conda some for matters like
black and auto pay paid as well as some
popular linters like pylons some fun
facts about python extension and vs code
it's the most popular extension in the
vs code marketplace really or so than
c-sharp yes that's very cool and even
better is Visual Studio code is now the
top free tool for Python developers
which is really exciting a lot of hype
around Python and hopefully by the end
of this you guys will understand a bit
more why that's so ok so it's an
extension which kind of implies that you
have to go get it yes yeah exactly what
Stahl vs code you don't have this python
extension right alright so yeah let's
show you how to download and install vs
Visual Studio code so the link to get
Visual Studio code if you don't have it
is code Visual Studio comm and your you
come to this excellent download page and
as you can see it auto detects which OS
I'm using ok and I can quickly grab a
copy of vs code I already have it
installed but I'm sure we get the idea
there and once you have Visual Studio
code you are going to open it you're
gonna see this welcome screen and this
welcome screen has tools that allow you
to customize it has this wonderful
activity bar here which gives you access
to all of your extensions that you have
installed and so after you download
Visual Studio code and you want to use
Python you have to go get the Python
extender ok so to do that you're gonna
go to the extensions badge here and I'm
gonna type Python and because it's the
most popular it's gonna come up right at
the top and you're gonna see the Python
extension for Microsoft the Python 4 vs
code or the Python extension or no if
you want the one that has the green star
here ok good question the one that you
worked on the one that I where not that
those are there what not that there's
anything wrong with those other ones but
this is the one you were definitely
defecate and so as you can see I've
already installed this so it says
uninstall which I'm not going to do but
there'll be an install badge I can click
and you can also see that we have some
quick tips here on how to get started
kind of the things I'm gonna cover today
so you need to install vs code which
we've done yeah you need to install the
extension which I've done okay and then
the third thing you need is an
installation of Python on your machine
right yeah one mixed misconception we
find is that some people often think
that the Python extension for vs code
comes with Python and it does not
currently and so one way to get around
that is depending on which OS you're on
for Windows we recommend going to Python
org which I have here to download the
latest release of python on mac a brew
install works fine and for linux
typically the bundled version of python
that comes with the linux works well to
get all of these features and other
python extension got it
so I'm good all right awesome and now we
got code we got the extension we got
python we do we do I have Python alright
perfect okay and so let's get started
let's get um people accustomed to the UI
here because it is a bit different to
get on-boarded okay and so now that i
have the extension as you can see i have
the file explorer here and when i open a
folder i'm gonna be able to see the tree
view of that folder see all the
dependencies and all the files within
there I have a debugger icon which we'll
talk about later
and I have a lot of other things vs code
comes in box with source control and so
I can use my favorite repos connect to
those and do all of that stuff I know
and love and we also have the tool bar
down here which allows you to see I'm
signing into Azure currently I have live
the live share extension installed I
have my tool bar up here all that good
stuff okay and so what I now want to do
is create a folder and let's get started
playing around some yeah how does that
sound sounds great and another cool
thing is by default when you install
code on a vs code on windows it adds
code to a vs code to the path and I'll
show you exactly what that means so what
I want to do is I want to navigate to my
command prompt and I'm going to find
demos folder that I have here and I'm
gonna create a new folder for us I'm
gonna call it vs toolbox mm-hmm and I'm
gonna you know navigate to that folder
and now what's really cool is because I
have vs code on the path on my Windows
machine all they have to do is type code
dots into the command prompt and it will
open up an instance a vs code inside of
that folder okay and you can see that
for my file explorer here so you can
open the folder from code you can go to
the folder and launch code from that
location exactly on Linux and Mac you
have to run a command to get vs code on
path but it's super handy when you're if
your command line focus yeah alien
dragon and so now what I'm gonna do
actually is create a new file and so
this is the important part of activating
the python extension in order for the
extension to activate which you're
seeing down there activating extension
you need to select a Python folder or
sorry excuse me a Python file okay dot P
Y is the you know file type and as you
can see I am immediately to verify that
that extension is activated I actually
have python down here in my toolbar and
it if I click on this it gives me the
list of all the different interpreters I
have installed on my machine for python
so you can see all came when you
installed Python
well I've installed multiple different
versions okay for different reasons for
testing for the laying around but these
are all the interpreter versions I have
and us the extension can pick up most of
those if they are in the standard places
which they typically are when you
install python so pretty cool stuff
there cool so we created our file and so
now what I want to do is I want to talk
about the command palette and so that's
gonna be super helpful for us because
for developers who are a bit more
command-line driven you know you kind of
want to have that terminal experience
inside the editor so in order to get to
what I call the command palette you're
gonna do on a Windows machine ctrl shift
P to bring up the come
and again the command palette has all
the commands you could ever want and
love for Python and those all those
commands for Python are denoted by
Python : okay and then you can scroll
down the entire list to get anything
that you want I am after create terminal
because I want to pull up a terminal for
some command line driven stuff that I'm
gonna talk about now okay cool so what's
really cool here is that again I can get
start editing we start writing some code
so if I write print you can see that
immediately I'm starting to get what we
call intelligence as well as some
documentation so let's say I wasn't
familiar with the print statement I can
scroll over to this documentation tool
tip here and I can see exactly what
parameters it takes and for this I just
want to print hello world okay and cool
and to run this this is actually
something we've recently added a couple
of releases ago is the green run-button
so I can actually just run my code with
this button and it prints out in the
terminal hello world cool our classic
example for coding hello world all right
perfect and that's cool now the next
thing I want to talk about which is
really important for Python development
is the concept of a virtual environment
are you from our virtual environments
rather that much no ok so I'll explain
briefly what those are so in Python you
can have application a and B let's say
I'm a developer I'm working on two
different applications however each
application requires separate versions
of packages in order to function
correctly and if I were to include all
of those different package versions in
the same single application or same
environment there's a possibility I
might have conflicts some code may not
run something may get broken and so
typically what we recommend for Python
developers is to create a virtual
environment which I'm gonna show you how
to do now cool so back to my command
line here so I'm in my vs toolbox folder
I have my hello dot PI file print hello
world we're all good so there are
different commands depending on the OS
you're using I'm actually going to show
you the windows command
and also we can just look at the Linux
Mac command but in order to run to
create a virtual environment from the
command line what I want to do is I want
to type PI short for Python - 3 for the
version of Python I'm going to use - M
which is saying OK I'm gonna pass a
module that I want you to use and this
module is called vegan for short for
virtual environment which makes sense
the end and I'm actually gonna call our
virtual environment give me any name you
want what's your favorite favorite
folder name my favorite folder name
pictures pictures cool what's really
cool as you notice this pop-up that
comes it says we noticed a new virtual
environment has been created do you want
to select it for the workspace folder
what's really cool about that is if I
select yes and navigate to my . vs code
folder here you'll see that we include
this line with a path to that pictures
virtual environment so the next time I
open this folder I'll already be inside
of this virtual environment which you
can see is being denoted here pictures
virtual environment and so I can get
more productive more quickly the next
time and that's not an actual folder on
the hard drive right so it creates a
local copy actually good question it
creates a local copy of Python for this
workspace ok and you can see the list of
scripts that this includes as well as
all of the libraries that you may have
in that virtual environment but again
it's just local to this workspace so
that way your application can get all of
the stuff inside of that virtual
environment so actually and it sticks
around if I exit code come back in I can
have access to that environment or do I
have to recreate it exactly you have
access to that environment so what I'm
actually gonna do now is hello world is
exciting but I actually want to show you
a web app that I have with the virtual
environment already created ok so let's
actually answer your question right now
so in order to close this I'm gonna go
to file close folder mm-hmm
and there are a couple of ways I can
open a new folder I can go to file open
folder here and navigate on my file
explorer there's the Start menu which
allows me to open folder but actually
the the demo I want is sentiment API and
it's under my recent so why not just
click it they okay cool
and so a couple of things to immediately
notice about this application is it's a
simple web application using the popular
Python package flask which is a way to
just create simple web applications and
to answer your question Robert I have a
virtual environment here called vs
toolbox and again I pre created this so
it's saved when I opened it back up
what's even better is that I could
actually activate that virtual
environment inside the terminal in two
ways
so if your command line driven again the
way in which you're gonna activate a
virtual environment on a Windows machine
is you're gonna start with the virtual
environment name so vs toolbox backslash
because we're on Windows scripts
backslash activate and you'll see that
the virtual environment is activated by
this parentheses with the virtual
environment name so then is that
information store like in source control
so if I take this up put it in github
go home clone it and bring it down
locally I have not only the code but
also the environment information yeah
absolutely if you want to share the
virtual environment with developers and
your team or with friends you definitely
can do that I also show you or you can
just create a new one but I'll show you
we've talked a little bit about that but
I think it'll come full circle in a
minute another quick way you can
activate this virtual environment if you
don't want to have to remember sort of
that path to the activate file what you
can do on a Windows machine is
control-shift backtick and what it'll do
is it'll open a new terminal for you
with this virtual environment already
installed ok
I already activated excuse me so some
really cool stuff here and let's explore
the editor for a minute so you guys or
everyone has probably noticed the yellow
squiggles that are appearing here these
Swagger's squiggles or what we call
linting messages and so what's important
to know is that the first time you
install the python extension it's gonna
ask if you want to install al enter the
default currently is pilant and so it is
gonna ask you if you want to use
Thailand but we also support other other
linting tools like flaky etc I and so
what you're seeing here are these
limiting messages so if I hover over
those linting messages it's telling me
it's saying hey I can't find unresolved
import text blob and so what that
essentially means is that it can't find
this package inside of my virtual
environment so it's giving me an error
which is super useful because it gives
me a diagnostic or a problem which I can
also view under problems here and you
see that I have the list of problems
unresolved import flask unresolved
import text blob and so what we can do
actually is install those and one thing
that's also different about this folder
compared to the last folder we created
is that I have this requirements dot txt
file here and for people who don't know
for Python developers this is just a
list of all the dependencies that my
application needs to function properly
so back to your original point depending
on the kind of setup you prefer with
source control you may send up your
virtual environment so people can
download and just activate it or you
might just send up the requirements txt
file and allow people to first create a
virtual environment and then install all
the packages thing ok
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
install those packages from this
requirements a txt file so back to my
command line notice again that I'm still
inside this virtual environment because
I want all these packages contained
locally to this application so I'm gonna
go pip install - R and then requirements
dot txt and hit enter and what you're
gonna notice is you're gonna notice that
it's going to find those packages and
install them for me it's getting the
list I've downloaded these before so
it's just using the cached versions of
these guys
and what's important to note is that
while it installed when it installs
these you're gonna notice that these
error messages are gonna go away which
is really cool so while it's installing
those packages let's explore this
application a bit and so what this is as
I said before it's a simple flask app so
what I'm doing here is I'm essentially
creating a flask app that's contained
inside this folder called startup I have
a simple home page here which is just
saying you know Python loves vs toolbox
okay and this is actually a really cool
application because it's not only just a
simple web application but it's a
sentiment API is the title of the folder
denotes so what this is gonna allow us
to do is it's gonna allow us to hit an
endpoint with a word and this API is
gonna help us determine the sentiment of
that word because maybe I just need help
determining you know if what kind of
sentiment words have and so very cool I
finished installing the packages for us
and noticed that my problems went away
and suddenly if I hover over flask I get
documentation for it
text blob I get module text blob which
is really cool cool stuff okay so now
what I want us to do we explored this
application so let's actually run this
application there a couple of ways you
can run it I want to run it using the
debugger because I also want to use this
as a moment to talk about debugging and
kind of what that gets you as I stated
previously this is a sentiment API
pretty simple only you know less than
perhaps 10 lines of code if you take out
all the comments in the spaces and
that's again the beauty of Python to
your earlier point and less than you
know 20 lines of code essentially I can
create a powerful sentiment API okay and
I have some to do's for myself actually
I need to actually build the API so if I
scroll down to line 13 this is actually
the route that's creating that endpoint
that will allow us to send a word in and
get the sentiment back out and so what I
want to do is how this module is working
is it's saying it's gonna take in that
message if the sentiment score is
greater than 0 we're gonna determine it
we're gonna say it's positive ok it's
less than 0 it's negative
and so what I'm gonna do is I'm actually
gonna write that out so if text blob I'm
using that package and notice I'm
getting my intellisense here so I'm
gonna tap to accept that message again
is what I want so if the message has a
sentiment and notice that again this
intellisense with the documentation
which is allowing me to learn as I type
dot polarity is less than zero then I'm
gonna reassign that sentiment I'm gonna
say okay you're negative trying to type
at the same time and let's get rid of my
comment here so how does text blob have
a sentiment property sorry explode dot
sentiment oh the beauty of the text blow
up a kid really yeah sentiment built-in
yeah that which is another cool thing
about Python okay I could very well
create my own sense I'm an API from
scratch if I wanted to but why in
reinvent the wheel I've never seen a
text box that I've ever used to have
that built into it right so what it
actually does that passes in that
message the text blob module okay and
then it does some stuff under the hood
and cool since molarity etc so we
reassigned that sentiment is negative
and then what I'm actually gonna do is
I'm gonna return that sentiment on the
page of my web application page which
you'll see in a second so cool let's run
the application all right I'm gonna run
it using the debugger actually because
there are a couple of things I want to
talk about so let's set a breakpoint on
line 15 notice that I clicked to the
left of the new line number which is
called the gutter for those of you who
are used to debugging it's gonna be the
same kind of feel for those who aren't
free or not it's super easy to get
started with the debugger so to start
this there are a couple of ways I can
run my debugger and I'm going to just
collapse that so I can give you full
attention here I can use the toolbar
mm-hmm click debug and click start
debugging it also has the keyboard
shortcut f5 and so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to start doing that and
notice that when I click start debugging
gonna present the bug configuration menu
and we have a list of popular templates
that we know Python developers use
remember earlier I mentioned that this
is a flask app yeah and so you can see
that flask is in that configuration list
and so that's what I want and I'm gonna
select it
the next step for debugging a web app is
entering the path to my startup file
remember I said that this startup file
is contained inside of a folder cards
called startup so what I actually want
to do is I want to tweak this path a
little bit to actually point to my
startup file that is creating my flask
app we'll just start up /opt up hi
and once I hit enter it's going to start
debugging for me and notice that this
tool bar down here changes to orange to
denote that I'm in debugging mode and
another cool thing is that the bug icon
here becomes highlighted in white so you
can see that I'm also debugging as well
I guess it did
it did yeah okay I've never noticed that
yeah it's a pretty cool nifty thing um
but at the same time to remember I never
tend to notice these things like back
remember the big controversy over the
individual studio the menu choices at
the top for all caps and it was a big
controversy but actually predates in my
time okay so anyway I just covered that
because there was a controversy no yes
about me let's get back to the app yes
so to debug a web app another thing that
people getting started with web apps may
not know is that in order to hit that
break point that I've said on line 15 I
actually need to navigate to the URL
that it's giving me here okay so it
tells me that it's running on this URL
and what's really cool is that inside vs
code in order to get to that URL I can
either copy and paste it into my browser
of choice or I can just control click
which I'm going to do you can see it
says vs Python loves vs toolbox and
notice that because I set this
breakpoint inside of the app rel that
defines that message
I actually in order to hit that break
point I need to send a message to the
API exactly so let's do it
give me what's the phrase that you love
or maybe want to know the sense of
enough I don't know let's say champion
champion let's see what the sentiment of
champion is so notice that I have this
wheel spinning here because we are in
the middle of the world series and and
either today or tomorrow there will be a
champion crowned so oh wow well let's
see what's the sentiment so you can tell
that vs code the icon here is blinking
orange which means that it did something
magical and what it's done is it's hit
this breakpoint inside of our API and
let's explore the debug menu for a menu
minutes ensues me so notice that it got
our message champion this is our locals
variable window I can also have my watch
window I have my call stack all of this
good stuff and I can also step through
lines so to step over I can actually use
the debug toolbar there or I can just
f10 so I'm gonna use the GUI there and
you notice that as I step it said okay
remember we say that we determine all
sentiments be positive at first and then
we run them through this if statement so
I'm just gonna step over again and in
order to continue I can either hit the
arrow here to continue and run it all
the way through or I can just hit f5 so
I'm gonna hit continue again and if I
navigate back to my API I see that our
champion is positive nice yeah
pretty cool alright let's let's do
another toast let's do another test yeah
let's let's test a new message okay
let's test a new message this time I'm
gonna rerun this but I mean rerun it a
different way still using the debugger
but a slightly different way so this
time to run this application with the
breakpoint set on line 15 I'm going to
use my debug icon that I mentioned
earlier and here's what's really cool
about this is that the debug icon gives
me access to the configuration menu that
I saw before so if I click this drop
down and select add configuration what
it's going to do and then I have to hit
the
green play button start debugging it's
gonna send me to that same debug
configuration menu and you may be
wondering
Tyreke why do I have to type this again
and it's because our configuration last
time wasn't saved and so by going
through these steps we're going through
now we're saving that configuration and
I will prove that to you in a second so
I'm going to navigate to flask again put
that path and notice that it creates
this file called launch JSON yeah we
find that this launch file is very scary
or intimidating for people who are first
starting out with vs code but fear not
it's simply an array of it's a JSON JSON
format it's an array with a list of
different configurations but notice that
everything saved it's saved right and my
startup path is saved I have some
different arguments here which are on by
default and to show you where it gets
saved if you navigate back to your file
explorer by using the Explorer button
here the dot vs code folder if there
wasn't one created before it'll be
created for you and you'll have that
launch configuration saved and this is
important because again you don't have
to go through the startup steps again to
save it so let's go back to my debugger
and you notice see it says this time
instead of add configuration or no
configuration like it said before I get
Python flask another important thing to
realize about debugging is that notice
that I'm currently inside of the launch
JSON file if I start the debugger here
it'll actually throw an error because it
thinks I'm trying to debug this JSON Wow
so in order to avoid that I need to go
back actually to the file that I'm
trying to debug and so we're gonna hit
our green play button
and again I need to navigate - so let's
try another word alright so this is a
test of the sentiment so I'm from Boston
okay and in Boston when we like
something like this we'd say it's wicked
cool we kick now wicked has a sentiment
of negative but cool has a sentiment of
positive so let's see what happens let's
see how text blob handles it wicked cool
okay and notice again it's flashing
orange it means it hit the breakpoint
and it's verified that it hits the
breakpoint by the yellow line here yeah
and what's also really cool is that all
the information you're getting in the
variables window here you can actually
hover over variables here yeah and you
get the tooltips which it's not playing
nice with you there you go is shy at
first but here we go you can see all the
different properties and again to
continue I'm gonna press f5 and I'm
gonna navigate back to this excellent if
it says wicked color like this yeah
pretty cool very good yeah it's very
awesome and again to recap that if you
start debugging from the toolbar here
you don't get that configuration saved
right and so and actually to get that
safe to save to make you more productive
than next time you want to use the debug
icon and add a configuration cool which
is really really cool stuff so let's
recap a little bit of what we talked
about because I know that we've covered
a lot so using virtual environments
which we talked about to help you manage
packages for different applications so
creating new environments depending on
if you're a Mac or Linux user or a
Windows user the commands are there okay
you can then the command I use that I
didn't really touch on at the time but
now I'm going to as the pip install -
are requirements at txt that's if your
file or if your project has one of those
you can create a virtual environment
first and then you can install the
requirements that are there you can also
install individual module names if you
want okay
getting started with debugging of course
there are multiple ways you can do this
but the way that I reckon
the way that I like to do it is actually
using the bug icon right
which takes me to the debug
configuration menu I can click that drop
down hit at configuration I can choose
my configuration of what I want to do
second time you have to retype all of
that cuz you didn't save it you're gonna
hit straight to here right exactly
exactly put the path to that web
application and that launch JSON gets
created and then remember you don't want
to debug the launch dot JSON file you
actually want to go back to the Python
file that you're interested in and then
hit the green Run button okay pretty
cool stuff and that's about all I have
for you guys today just I think about
that getting a start experience cool so
for more information people can go to
aka.ms/offweb yeah a getting started
tutorial there it's more information on
on Python within Visual Studio code
where it's a good place for people to go
to learn Python in general there's a lot
of documentation online our getting
started I think tutorial will teach you
links out to other things other material
that is useful but yeah any search for
example if you want to learn about flask
the flask documentation that they have
excellent okay
if you ever have any questions about
getting started though and you want to
interact directly with the team our
twitter twitter handle excuse me is at
python vs code okay all one word and we
are always interacting with users trying
to understand what experiences work best
in which don't fantastic yeah awesome
thanks for having me nice try coming on
there's a great introduction to not only
Visual Studio code for folks that have
been played around with it a lot but
also how you get started using Python
that's awesome perfect yeah thanks thank
you hope you guys enjoyed that and we
will see you next time on visual studio
toolbox
[Music]
you